how's it going everybody it's Warren and
it seemed like we were supposed to get
the second official trailer for
spider-man far from home this morning
however we did not what just happened
instead Tom Holland posted on Instagram
three new posters for spider-man far
from home this was obviously a big
letdown but as it turns out we did not
get the trailer for a pretty good reason
as we all know spider-man far from home
takes place after the events of Avengers
endgame this has been confirmed by Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
and according to insider Daniel RPK we
will not be receiving a new spider-man
far from home trailer until after
Avengers end game hits theaters the
reason is because the second spider-man
far from home trailer is supposed to
include heavy spoilers for avengers
endgame now there is obviously a lot of
speculation that follows this especially
since we did not see tony stark at all
in the spider-man far from home trailer
and Marvel has been keeping everything
about Avengers end games such a secret
it makes sense that they wouldn't show
us the second spider-man far from home
trailer before Avengers end game comes
out that way we still go into Avengers
in game pretty blindly not knowing too
much about the movie
so although we did not get the second
spider-man far from home trailer today
like we thought it is for a good reason
so we avoid all spoilers for Avengers
end game the new posters are really cool
but of course they do not reveal
anything new about spider-man far from
home or Avengers in game so let me know
what you think about there being huge
spoilers and the spider-man far from
home second official trailer what do you
think they are let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and a
reminder about my giveaway giving away
five imax tickets if you'd like to
interfere your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on everything relating to
marvel avengers endgame and spider-man
fart from home as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
well so much for watching wolf wolf